n nah
nah
[Music]
n
sh
[Music]
come
n
[Music]
what's
going
[Music]
a
what is it
doing all I see is the top of my ha what
is
that
yo yo yo yo what's going on guys sorry
about that uh last week I changed stuff
up so I had to uh re bring stuff down
all right what's going on you guys the
attic show we talk about the past
present future gaming got my co-host
with me d g and know you guys I know
what you're thinking damn addict you you
you did that fast we already doing the
intros what's going on Dirk nothing much
man what's going on with you
brother I just went and had a three mile
walk so I'm drinking water oh
okay sounds good man three miles that's
a that's a nice hike man yeah it was on
a track so I was yeah bro you are frozen
cuz you're Frozen on my side too even on
Zoom you're Frozen I'm looking at the
stream I'm not frozen but you are
Frozen all right I should be good
now uh problem is I switched from yep
you one to the other so what's going you
guys appreciate you coming through here
you know we are going to since you are
uh since you had uh family stuff last
week let's recap the the leaks real
quick because I I know a lot of people
wanted our back and forth with it so uh
we won't stick into this too much let me
get to the edit video screen so that uh
you know the the people don't come after
me yeah BT Maverick I'm from Detroit
bro all right so let
me addict
stamps I call it adct stamps I think
that's funny adct
stamps yeah adct stamps yeah get those
Adam stamps right man sucker you J
turkey
I love this does he really say that
exact sentence in the game uh no oh I
don't think so but that's you know
that's how black people used to talk in
the 70s from what I understand you know
I was a I was a baby in the 70s but
watching some of them old movies I I was
watching um Power MH and um Jerome kind
of talks like that so I guess that's
like a
stereotype Yeah man so first one we're
going to talk about the Xbox leaks
and uh we are 9 Minutes in all right I
appreciate you guys being patient with
me man normally I have the time stamps
and everything up but I I had to start
walking again like I need to get more
rotation of walking and I couldn't do it
after the show I had to do it before so
all right let's talk about this dirt
let's talk about it man the the infamous
leaks you
know what give me your your your quick
summary and your thoughts on
it well you know Phil himself said that
some things changed but if you want to
go right and know exactly by the leaks
as of as of they're set in stone I think
it shows that
um uh you know if you think about the
the future from Bethesda because those
are like but there the games are the
only games that leaked as far as Xbox
first party Studios but some of the
things feel said I think people see what
he said and they instantly misinterpret
what he
said um there's so many different things
that was said but as far as the games I
love some of the games that they you
know from dishonor 3 to you know you
know some other stuff um the hardware is
very interesting bro if it's you know
still going as schedule like Phil did
say these are leaks from years ago from
emails from 3 years ago so it doesn't
mean these still these things are still
going to happen but far as the
hardware I
mean some people say they don't like the
digital Xbox series X it doesn't matter
to me because I'm All Digital anyway um
but if you know if they can get the
counil more efficient U you know two
terabytes I'm down with it um so I kind
of forget some of the leak adct don't
all right so excuse me was the Xbox uh
the Xbox new interation of the Xbox
series X the interation of the Xbox
series s there was the the leak
conversation between Phil Sarah and like
two other Executives saying that they
don't hit their quotas by 2027 that they
might leave the console industry that
one now let me ask you that one like
before you finish to me from what I read
is that somebody had like like put out a
CH
and it seemed like the chart was kind of
wrong in PH eyes now maybe I'm
misinterpreted wrong because I'm a bot
but it seemed like he said if things
wind up like this we'll be out of the
game and Industry in in
2027 um if that's how the chart was or
the prediction chart or whatever the
chart was that's how I took it I don't
it's obviously I don't think feel saying
if we don't see this we're out of here
in 2027 that's like four years from now
not come on I don't really see that
especially all of the Investments
they're making
but um see like this stupid person in
see see Pony's running with it because
they ain't got nothing El to do he said
RP Xbox 2027 N I didn't take it like
that I'm just saying you know my thing
is if they were going to leave the
industry here's the thing I think that
there is a quota eventually that they
would bow down and go third party if
Game Pass isn't hitting their goals but
2027 is too soon uh to
me halfway through next Generation if
they haven't hit the goals that they
internally have that's when they'll
start hitting the breaks maybe talking
about you know uh Game Pass if it's if
it's sustainable to them in the long
term uh but to me you don't invest
millions and millions and millions of
dollars into R uh to you know research
and development R&D to the new Xbox and
then explain where that money went like
to me it makes more sense to go through
with the Next Generation M and see where
it goes a few years into that generation
cuz you know I made a video today and it
was just like look like Microsoft has
all the tools they need to really
compete with PlayStation now they they
have the big marketing deals such as
Call of Duty OverWatch they have a huge
lineup of first party Studios they have
game pass they have the ability to reach
in and pick up any of these Indie
developers and offer them a couple
million to come on their Subscription
Service like they really do have a huge
portfolio that one would think after a
certain amount of time you'll start
seeing return imagine we seen this with
Starfield D what happens when hellblade
comes out and it's a good game AOW comes
out and it's a good game Fable comes out
and it's a good game perfect art comes
out and it's a good day out of Wars 2
come out it's a good game uh Oblivion
the Remake Fallout 3
remake it's obviously two those last two
games most likely are going to be on
Playstation Indiana Jones like look and
that that goes off if if the games are
good but that's a
given like that though that doesn't need
to be said that is a given the games
have to be good mhm and to
me there's no reason and I know me and
you have went back and forth even if
Game Pass isn't hitting the way they
should they'll probably stay afloat just
off the sales on Steam
alone and that's why I'm like look Game
Pass is a huge
Juggernaut but at the end of the day
even before they had Game
Pass Services was never Xbox's issues
what was it there it was games it was
games and as long as you have games in
your your corner and they make sure
these games do what they're supposed to
they're going to be successful mhm yep
content is the key not only do they want
new people to subscribe to Game Pass
they want to keep the the the fan base
that they have and how do you do that
with constant content good quality
content smaller games dropping day one
third party games some third party games
dropping day one and bro they about to
have the biggest well I would say the
second biggest third party game but if
you want to go by annually the biggest
third party game every year so that's
about to be under their umbrella I don't
have to technically do this on here
because this is for IOP but you know I
try to give value to the companies that
do give us opportunities for Stuff hex
gaming let me customize a PlayStation 4
census controller like I don't know if
five that that's a five five controller
yeah um so unfortunately like the
lighting is really bad oh there it is
yeah his own yeah nice so it's got these
back pedals on it
too oh okay yeah so it I would say it's
like more on lines with the edge
controller MH um actually what I'll do
is I'll give you their info uh when we
get off the show cuz cuz they gave uh
King an Xbox controller and you know uh
they're a little pricey but you know I
was playing it a little bit I I liked it
like it feels good uh King loves his
Xbox One okay uh so you know sometimes
you got to pay for that preum now I will
agree with King they they boxing ain't
it like really like normally when you
get a controller like Xbox is really sh
like that the flap that you just raise
up yeah this you pull out and it's like
wrapped in this little bubble wrap thing
it's not a bubble wrap it's like a piece
of slim paper that's put over it and and
like the thing isn't even customized to
it so it's like jiggling in it a little
bit like it's like man I get it I get it
I get it uh so all right all right so
here's my
thing
just correct me if I'm wrong D mhm just
the Bethesda game leak
is more games than than PlayStation
probably has scheduled for the next 10
years you're damn right it is just the
Bethesda one that doesn't mean
Activision when that is finalized which
most likely that's going through and
that doesn't mean the Xbox first party
Studios just
Bethesda Yep they're publisher and
Publishers that publisher themselves
have eight
Studios and uh listen man um at the end
of the day adct this is a strong Xbox if
this league is true Bethesda is looking
really
good um they hell this year they dropped
what two two games or is it three no
three games um you want you know like
high five Russ red fall and um Starfield
you know people want to you know like we
don't like to mention red fall too much
but you know I thought the game was okay
but
best effort didn't you notice in TGs
we'll get to that here in a second oh
you know Phil Spencer talked about about
the games that's coming up this year he
left
redf did he he talking he brought up he
brought up high five Rush Starfield he
said high-fi rush in the in the recently
released Starfield and the soon to be
released Forza just
completely man it is what it is
sometimes if if it's something you not
like if there's a moment in your life or
in the moment that you're not too proud
of you you try to you know avoid it I
mean to be fair I I get it I do I get it
I get it I get all right so let's let's
let's move on from from the leaks you
know I'm sure he talked about the leaks
quite a bit and I talked about the leaks
a lot too so we don't really got to go
too much into the
leaks let's let's go
into this thing that we're talking about
yo hold on Louis is that true what let
me he said Jason sh said Jim Ryan to
stepped me down to sword let me see if
that's true bro no way is that
true he said Jason sh okay like he
hasn't blocked me let me see Louis don't
don't play because I hate when people
come here with
misinformation oh [__] oh I'm
sorry
uh bro add he breaking news Jason shrier
is breaking PlayStation B St Jim Ryan is
stepping down two
sources wait wait wait wait are you
serious I'm dead I'm about to Jason Sher
this is the real Jason
Sher and it was three minutes ago let me
send it to you bro breaking news
PlayStation boss Jim Riot is stepping
down whoa tastes good whoa throw it away
whoa a bro you got to be kidding
me you gotta be kidding
me oh God ain't no listen Jason he's you
know he's not that great know he uh as
far as you know blocking people block he
knows his stuff though I got to get King
in here bro no I got to get King in here
I got
in here oh my God shout out to you
Louis you know what I can't get King in
here cuz I I'm not going to do Fame like
that cuz King let's call King let's
let's
bro oh snap okay hold up hold up hold up
hold
up can you guys
hear [__] can you guys hear that y uh
first off uh you're you're live on uh on
the on the attic show uh I'm posting
something in the chat okay oh snap it's
you're you're going to go crazy it just
went live it's breaking
news now I'm putting it in the chat go
read that on the Facebook CH BR I I want
your initial reaction when you see it oh
my
God one
second got all oh here we go everyone
listen
hold on Playstation dream Ryan is
stepping down two S turn Bloomberg I
told you Phil
[Laughter]
was he's dead I told y he wasn't G
survive that he snitches snitches
stitches I told you what he's going to
that boy up he love that boy you Ain see
that boy s
he in Witness Protection Program oh God
him I told you he was going to slump PHS
a killer
bro can you hear
King huh no I was asking can they hear
King yeah I can hear clearly it's crazy
man are you in are you sleeping no I'm
in the gym oh all right um I will
definitely uh be listening to your
thoughts uh King will be on fain's
pocket today correct
yes I be on Fame podcast at uh 7 Eastern
Standard Time I don't know he's like on
mountain time or something crazy like
that but I'll be there Jim won't be
there Jim won't be at a PlayStation and
I told you ain't gonna be no PlayStation
6 I told you
remember what did
I a out of it and everybody was like n
Jim he's good PlayStation's in first
place y wallet looking like last place
bro XO that PlayStation is on
God
bro oh my God yo okay okay okay okay
everyone right now post on Twitter that
we talking about Jim Ryan is out of
there
yo I'm thinking the Sony big boys that
look B
I wonder y I can't wait to get some
details why he's stepping down they
ain't GNA tell you you know they ain't G
to tell you you don't think they gonna
tell you he he going to come up with
some some thing that say you know uh
I've decided to move on with my career
he's not they not could have say look
damn he he hasn't been hitting the
strides that he needs to like it's just
point blank [__] man you and we've been
saying this how long something something
weird about Jim Ryan Jim Ryan ain't
doing what nor what the past ones have
done he he's looking he was I always
said the PS4 you know they had great
leaders there from uh uh Jack Trenton to
you know Yoshida to Shawn Laden they had
great leaders right there silver afro
love that name by the way he said he's
not a gamer and I think that was the
biggest thing like look people could say
uh the dude that went to the Indies what
was his name cro or uh Yos Yoshida you
say what you want about that man but
what was he DK he was a gamer he was a
gamer shawnon you can say what you want
about Shawn Leon but what was Shawn
Leighton he was a gamer he actually
played games they yeah bro I'm telling
you listen man we can talk listen let's
be real right now at it let's be real
the PlayStation brand the PS4 was
amazing right so great great so consoles
the only reason the PS5 is Sly right now
is because the PS4 was dominant there's
no reason uh uh that Jim like Jim Ryan
is not causing the PS5 to sell it's
inertia right so when you think about
what's going on right now some of the
decisions being
made there's a lot of scrutiny Jim
Ryan's way from the crying about the ABK
deal from saying it's okay in emails
leaked emails and then live on on
Twitter and everything he's crying about
Xbox buying ABK
and maybe they don't have the growth
that Sony wants yo
imagine imagine first off King uh we
come look look we call King live on the
show he gave us his little bit of bars
but they're going to be got change the
title bro you got to change the title
with the uh show yeah but but guess
they're going to that that's going we're
going to end up talking about this half
the show bro you got to change the title
of the show Jim Ryan stepping down no
you got to put breaking Ryan is leaving
PlayStation or something like you got to
change breaking news Jim Ryan stepping
down this is
crazy hey I was about to go off on leou
I about say Lou don't come here with
this fraudulent news and I damn Lou
wasn't uh wasn't lying but fame
fame King you're gonna get King bars
you're gonna get King right after cuz we
already heard a little bit and the chat
knows where the where where it's going
go the source is Jason
Trier yo I I gotta listen to every
podcast this week every one of them oh
my God oh my God I wonder who replaces
him they should put Yoshida back in um
place to be honest with you promot him
back to where he was before I don't know
this is crazy this is go to show you
guys the PlayStation head just stepped
down this is show you guys all you
PlayStation guys that think everything
is great in PlayStation because they're
selling consoles it's more than console
sales at this point we told you guys
that Microsoft figured that out last
generation they figured that stuff out
man um I don't know why Jim Ryan is
stepping down maybe that's something he
wants to do or maybe it's some of the
Sony higher ups that's higher than him
say look man you ain't it you ain't it
buddy why don't you do us a favor go
ahead get out of here it could be too
you know maybe he's retiring how old is
Jim Ryan someone put in the chat how old
Jim Ryan is I need some early some chat
Jim Ryan guesses let's okay put people
put in there how old you think Jimmy Jam
j
m i me and we could probably Google it
but wow this is unbelievable this is
crazy
95 53 they going to get DME match 63 80
150 they say he going to get hey my boy
Garcia said they going to get D matrick
to replace him oh man oh my let's let's
Google it let me
see how old is J is younger
than Phil's
55 he said older ran is 53 yeah he is
younger to Phil oh yeah he's young in
the field Peter Moore is 65 years old I
didn't know that yeah I mean that makes
sense yeah so Jim Ryan is 53 he's
younger he's two years younger than
phield Spencer damn but he looks older
than phield Spencer doesn't he someone
does Jim Ryan have a
uh does Jim Ryan have a
uh a Twitter account yeah but I don't
think he ever uses it yeah but right now
would be the time to use
it yo this is crazy it it it's it's
everywhere
now this is crazy so uh ACG said
interesting if Jim Ryan leaves I don't
know who to make gifts about yeah that's
true because a lot of my thumbnails have
Jim Ryan in them bro a lot of my
thumbnails like every one of my
thumbnails got Jim Ryan crying in it
damn I okay this is going to
be a bad take well it's going to be my
take I don't care if it's a bad take for
you guys I think he got to go I really
do because the thing is is as much as I
like clowning on these PlayStation guys
from week to
week I do think Jim Ryan was taking
PlayStation in a bad
Direction cuz I feel like there was a
lot of emphasis behind like games as a
service and it's okay to invest in that
area but I feel like it was pushing more
into that area than anything
else it just it's crazy man I don't even
this completely threw the whole show
into a right like oh man y hey hey hey
hey D what happens
next next is the conversation of who's
replacing him cuz uh we need to see
who's replacing him is it a person
that's more aggressive cuz Jim Ry is
pretty aggressive as far as you know
trying to take stuff away from Xbox and
things like that but who's replacing him
is the next question no no F Well the
first question is why is he leaving was
he fire or is he resigning that's the
question right those the questions
second is who's replacing him someone
said what if Sony gets
Reggie that would be that' be pretty
good for PlayStation Phil was replacing
Jimmy po that was yo that that that
would set the world on fire that would
suck bro and imagine the the PlayStation
Fanboys they go from talking smack about
him to um to saying oh you know he's
going to set the the once if uh do you
think Shawn Leighton comes back
Shon is with another company right yeah
he's like on like a I think he's like an
he's helping tenson was something if I
remember correctly I don't know what
what about
Bobby Bobby does make Activision
money Bobby C oh so someone said King
taking Jim's Place it was
play oh my God man
I look I get it people are are are
clowning me said that you're just I just
I didn't like the way they were going I
didn't you know and then you look at
something like this the
PS5 you're you're not seeing when it
comes to the PS5 I felt like this time
with the PS4 you've already started to
scene their successful games no think
about it since the p like it used to be
on like this term it feels like Phil
Spencer took all his chest Pieces away
and then he was there with an empty
board because he came into getting stuff
like Persona in there day uh get on on
his platform Yakuza a lot of Sega games
uh he just he had a lot of Japanese
support he had the Call of Duty
licensing he had all this to his to his
name and now we're at a point where he's
lost Persona exclusivity what it looks
like he has lost the yakos for
exclusivity he already is about to lose
the marketing rights for Call of
Duty he had is it more gy failures or a
more aggressive Xbox I think it's a
combination of both I think Jim has made
Playstation money at the cost of their
reputation because look at it what what
what was announced today for
PlayStation PC uh Horizon forbidden West
PC and what else The Definitive Edition
no no it's it's called the complete
edition the complete edition the
complete and it's $60 in only had to pay
for all the D all the DLC and stuff he
like someone said in score Enix Lo uh he
lost his score Enix thing yeah oh
W that's crazy man wasn't expecting that
Fame you want to come in here for a
second you got time wasn't you got a
couple seconds Fame I'm we we you get
King let me get 10 minut let me get 10
minutes of fame with with with
Fame damn what do you think
Fame what do you think Fame this is
crazy bro what's going on
F my phone is blowing up man so many
people sending me DMs like d you see
this D you see this yeah y'all I see it
this is unbelievable bro um
I'm just now not adct I'm at the point
I'm just
curious I'm so curious why he's stepping
out is he being forced to step down is
he stepping down voluntarily knowing you
know what hold up hold up hold I can't
do hold up okay let me let me grab
that let me send it to Jay du on fa on
Twitter what's going on my
dude I love I know you don't like J of
me and him are pretty good friends I
love poking at him with a big giant
stick when I can't
pause no I mean me going on
F ad all right all right let me change
things up it's
completely I like his screen
saver did I am I
[Laughter]
am
listen listen might call work tomorrow I
legit I walk in the door serious I walk
in the door to get a DM about lying
crying Jim Ryan and I am in disbelief
bro we found out live on show bro live
on show yo oh man it's it's crazy we we
from all this stuff dating back with
Activision and all the stuff going on
just for him to step down down did did
did you get in trouble for not you know
finishing the mission good question it's
it's like
a failure it's like I said saying Fame
he might have made them money but he
kind of cost them their reputation like
a little bit of it because uh he had so
many more tools before Phil started
taking them from him he had the Persona
franchise the Yakuza franchise Final
Fantasy he had all of these things and
SL the uh when he took all when he took
over he had the power narrative because
uh of the whole thing he had the whole
Xbox one thing you want to get technical
Jim Ryan dropped the biggest ball known
the man like he he had the opportunity
the privilege of taking Shawn leighton's
Legacy and stepping on Xbox until they
just went away he could he could have
killed Xbox he didn't do it then he
spent 3.5 billion on bung that ain't
doing [__] they just they're just
telling other franchises they can't go
anywhere tell Naughty Dog of all gaming
developers at Sony what they shouldn't
do should and shouldn't do come on man
that's naughty dog I don't care if it's
a multiplayer again that's naughty dog
and you got them canceling game yo
deviation games this game is trash don't
don't do it I'm telling you man this
this is crazy bro I can't wait to find
out more information about it
unbelievable you you know what on top of
like we just got those leaks of you know
those emails that was going out and like
I some people I did a did a 50 minutes
of fame the other day and I'm like don't
tell me that you gotta be professional
at all the time because I see how Jim
Ryan talking these emails and my man is
just as bad as everybody else on these
Twitter streets I really want I need
Jason Shri to do what Jason Shri does
and get the get some information let us
know someo what led to this man because
by all intents and
purposes PlayStation is just as
profitable as has been they're selling
consoles like crazy they got Spider-Man
2 along the way you mean to tell me that
Jim Ryan at this moment of time right
before the launch of probably what their
their only big game of the year right
and you have a an invisible road map
that we can't see and Microsoft is about
to close the deal with activism blizzard
and you're constantly having games that
are typically synonymous with
PlayStation and exclusive to PlayStation
also going on Xbox via Game Pass so on
and so forth and this is the time that
Jim Ryan leaves
PlayStation something crazy F bu got
told go ahead and clock out and and and
don't clock back in you P he had
security escort him to his office to get
his
stuff go go ahead and clock out big dog
because you had opportunity to destroy
Xbox and you did we we and you know
what's crazy I can't wait oh press
release for uh uh hold up I think
someone just sent me something hold
up oh no no it's a press release from uh
Jim oh oh Jim Ryan to retire next
spring and hakura to to to con or
whatever his name is to assume interim
CEO while keeping his current role at
Sony group stressed out man he he's
retiring I meaned I guess we if you guys
want we could go ahead and we could read
uh yeah you can read it yeah yeah let's
read it I don't read that well so does
anyone else want to read
it he's two years younger than Phil
Spencer man he's retiring
huh all right so hold
up let me grab uh I appreciate uh donatu
he's the one that uh gave me the the
press
release all right so let me cover this
down um Don I think I don't know if he's
a
let me put this in the
chat so you guys could read along with
us all
right here let me put it over the right
side of the
screen put it over me all right so it's
over fame a little bit but
right so any anybody coming to see me uh
stop
that I put it over me
exclusively I see the boy David put out
a video I can't yo I got I got your boy
on a podcast tonight King David I can't
the the
timing for me to have King David on
tonight when this happens
impeccable all right so uh play
PlayStation officially announced it too
yeah that's what I'm reading is on
Playstation thing all right so I I put
it in the chat uh if someone wants to
click it it's in the chat what I'm
reading right now is in the
chat oh I chat yeah no the the chat for
the uh podcast oh
oh if it does anyone want to read this
but me CU I'm telling you I got you okay
okay I got you I got you I got you yeah
uh as you have seen today in the news I
have announced my retirement after le 30
years at Sony interactive entertainment
I do not take this decision lightly and
I absolutely love siie and our community
but of late I've been finding it
increasingly difficult to strike the
right balance between having my home in
the UK and my job in the United States
as mentioned in press release I will
continue my role as president and CEO
until March 2024 effective April 1st
2024 uh here here hereo HT I I'm bad at
names I apologize will be appointed
interim CEO of siie while he continues
his current role as Sony group
Corporation I feel humbled at having the
opportunity to lead a company delivering
products that touch millions of lives
from a war-winning games to incredibly
immersive technical achievements deliver
by PlayStation 5 I immensely proud of
what we have achieved and very
optimistic for the future of Sony
interactive
entertainment from the from my beginning
in Europe it was clear that Sony had
built something truly special gener
later I am still amazed by excitement
and passion of the PlayStation Community
it is thanks to you that we have been
able to keep innovating and delivering
even greater experiences since 1994
generations of Gamers have inspired us
to do better to push the boundaries and
the results have been incredible thank
you from the bottom of my
heart yall on the way out the door Jim
lying
crying hey man last year was stressful
for him man like well like he did say if
uh if if XBox acquired ABK they can't
recover I guess he meant he couldn't
recover because he said you know I'm g
go I guess at the end of the day he
might just be leaving because he's just
stress and I get it you know you're
constantly have to go between two things
do you think do you believe he left on
his own or he was pushed
out you know what I'm not lie I'm like
5050 remember the the community was
seemingly they didn't like Jim Ryan
because it seemed like he was making
changes that they didn't want you know
from going of the Shawn Laden days of
exclusivity you know we not we're doing
single player and then you got this
future of gas titles you got you know
games going to PC and it's gonna be very
interesting to see how their Community
reacts because they went from The Hating
Jim Ryan to defending Jim Ryan to sort
of disliking him again I do think it's
it is a good chance he just he just
wants to retire right but you can't tell
me the fire he's that he's been under
over the last year and a half to two
years isn't didn't push him himself out
the door because you're constantly
having to answer to a group of people
who are on your bumper for every
decision you made which seems to be
counteractive to their arguments of
exclusivity of single player over the
shoulder third third party action
adventure games with some stealth
elements right now he talking about gas
you're talking about
I got a super chat I got a Super Chat
Jim is going to join the
constellation well I think hey FK oh I'm
sorry go Ahad I think there's a chance
that he's generally retiring uh you know
but I think there is some merits where
both of us could be true you know I
think he's retiring but I don't think
Sony was trying to keep him around
either you know what I'm saying it's
like it's like you know we we
interviewed Peter Mo and Peter Moore
said when he when he did that call and
said I'm
leaving they it seemed like they were
originally going to like try to get him
to stay but then when they told him
where he's going I can't compete with
that it's a rra uh it just it feels like
to me personally maybe I maybe they do
value him and I'm sure they value him to
some degree he makes the money but I do
feel like the past two years have been
rough on Playstation you know they they
they really haven't had a whole lot of
hits they've had a lot of raises they
they keep investing into stuff they've
had to drop Studios like that studio
they had they haven't announced like a
new IP in forever for a minute like I
think it's been a little rough for them
I really do yeah yeah see let me say you
something um as a response to what Fame
was saying I I agree what you're saying
but at the same time screwy comes with
the job right um Phil Spencer got
absolutely destroyed for years uh by
Xbox lack of games by Xbox being
destroyed in console sales even early
this year with red fall and CMA blocking
the deal Phil Spencer didn't back down
from doing that interview with kind of
funny games so if Jim
Ryan hand handle the scrutiny from
PlayStation guys because you know it
goes back to the old cliche everybody's
not going to like you or I'm sorry you
can't please everybody you can't please
everybody so if Jim Ryan can't handle
the scrutiny of of of what comes with
his
position maybe he's just not built for
it you know what I'm saying oh man CH
going to be
I'm getting I'm getting
messages the saying I already know you C
get up a video about Jim Ryan stepping
down we know all we gonna see is
this I might I might do two spins I
might do two spins on
that let me get these super chats for
you I appreciate it it's been crazy uh
let see Jack's 82 is anyone oh yeah they
night hold on oh we got a few the okay I
see the man who got them horns remember
for 34 months everybody pull on your
dancing shoes and Jamaican accents for
the homie gym damn Jamaican accents Doan
Knight with the two tears are streaming
out of the holes and dream C got face oh
come on Doan Knight be nice man we on
adct show right now uh ja 82 the five
Jim Ryan never invested in PlayStation
plus he never listened to the fans
investing in games we didn't ask for or
wanted it time for a change anyway all
right J 82 man rang G4 with the two oh
said Jim is going to join the
consolation yeah I thought was another
one um daku I'm sorry let me get these
older ones real quick I with the $2
super trat pack it up Jimbo pack it up
uh Angry therapist with the five gifted
uh uh member chat appreciate that
another $2 for the angry therapist J Jim
lies caught up with him uh am I starting
to read the stuff you did
uh not yet okay uh Adidas with the three
month member don't be surprised if Cas
was choose Xbox Next Generation idas
with another $2 Super Chat what's up
dirt Alvin with the $2 Super Chat Phil
beat Jim Ryan's legs in is that what I'm
reading
now I haven't got to that part you can
keep on going $2 super TR from the angry
therapist Jim must be must have been
stressed at PlayStation another $2 Super
Chat from J 82 remix remakes and
remasters is why Ryan is G another $2
Super Chat from Corey Jim coming over to
run
activ you say you going to run
Activision you want the play why of Xbox
like poaches and to go to Activision
yeah that would be that would drive the
internet into a frenzy oh man $2 Super
Chat from uh uh Dolan Knight it's all
dirt's fault
[Laughter]
j$ for range G4 if uh what if Jim Ryan
hacked PS then steps
down damn $5 Super Chat from Spartan 661
Jim Ryan looks uh looks and is going to
be acting like the famous chef that
curses a lot Gordon ramsy he kind of
looks like Gordon Ramsey yeah yeah you
do favor him a little bit Yeah they
favor yeah yeah um and then $2 from
Ellie look at Charlie Intel's last post
I don't know who that is that's the guy
I think he covers Call of Duty that's
the C guy yeah yeah let me see what he
said yeah I didn't even see all these
other other super chats before though
I'm glad you still got him on let me see
what he said uh oh I think he was uh
yeah he was referring to um the thing
that we at that was an old Super
Chat uh we got a member chat for the man
who got them horns
pause everybody put on your dancing
shoes and Jamaican accent for the homie
gym oh yeah now that's the one I got
okay uh $2 super trat from Doan Knight
tears are streaming out of the holes in
DC's face yeah we read that $5 super
trat from Jack's 82 Jim Ryan never
invested in PlayStation plus he never
listened to the fans invested in games
we didn't ask for or wanted it was it a
time for change anyway $2 Super Chat
from uh from uh rain G4 Jim is going to
join the constellation oh my god um $5
Super Chat from Nintendo the da otaku
let's check the stat
Falls to block ABK after def defacing PS
to do so Xbox becomes more profitable PS
road map is shambles they got him out of
here do you think they got him out of
there CU he couldn't stop the activation
thing he tried his ass out he he tried
his best but I I don't know you know who
knows bro behind closed doors we have no
idea $5 superat from let's burn 98 my
Lee burn 98 now we know why Jim was not
non-stop traveling to see the CMA poor
guy was
homesick oh $5 Super Chat from King is
overrated damn man it let him spell out
Dam
uh uh G uh uh CS2 comes out an hour ago
I didn't even catch this live wow crazy
crazy to Big gaming headlines in one day
what's
CS2 S2 I don't know what that is does
someone put in there what's
CS2 um $2 from bar uh barus hold the
line Phil maximan aelius Spencer one he
C $5 Super Chat from cobweb uh they
replac Jim with the CFO in my experience
when they bring in the financial team
the house is on fire I bet some budget
cuts are next oh PA wee is a very smart
dude by the way very educated guy man so
he he usually knows what he talking
about that that would make sense that
would make sense you got $5 Super Chat
from mdy what if Jim's resonation was
one of the hackers demands
Bobby we want Jim up out of there we
give we want Jim up out of there we want
$10 million and they're like well we
ain't giving you $10 million but we'll
get rid of JY that's good enough we
won't do
[Laughter]
it oh man oh that was that that was a
good one all right so sorry uh uh DK
what was you
saying um no I was saying car wee he's a
very smart guy very educated young man
um I usually listen I mean I listen to
everybody but when he says something I
really pay close attention to what he
said because he's usually on point um
Mandy uh is it MD with the five said
what if Jim resonation was one of the
hackers oh you did said that Bobby CCH
is going to need oh you s anyone had D
mat number okay I'm sorry you just read
what happens if they get Tom matrick
that's never happening but no that's
never happen bro this is this is crazy I
I
gotta did you see what Stein said Stein
um did you see fames
background oh man yo DT tomorrow your
Darkness podcast oh man I'm about to
make the thumbnail right now after the
show after the show this my one of my
last Jim you know Jim Ry are every one
of my thumbnails uh oh what are you
gonna do now I'm still gonna put them on
there until they announce the new oh my
look at that look background I love it
oh man ah
bro like crazy regard at the end of the
day regardless if he actually wanted to
you know resign or or didn't resign
that's kind of irrelevant to the point
we joke around but you know I I hope the
dude if if he's being like hit that hard
mentally get get some rest job ain't
worth it man that dude most likely he
don't need the money anymore let's be
real he's been there for a minute he's
good it's just like if you need that go
go do that but it it's it is fun to
speculate like is it really him leaving
because he's just homesick and he's
having a hard time doing this or is the
house on the fire and you know we C wee
is good point you know in my experience
when you bring in the financial team the
house is on fire I bet some budget cuts
are next uh and they they've been
they've been buying these Studios too by
the way so that's why you need these gas
games they need these gas games we bring
in some extra Revenue so we and all
jokes aside right again we talked about
it if if if he truly is having you know
it's mental health stuff like that CU I
always got a special place in my heart
for men who take care of they of they
their mental health or someone who
struggle with it much respect for that
all jokes as side right that's what it
is take care of yourself retired do your
thing but it's not lost upon us what you
got saying about the financial team
because they're investing into gas
there's a chance that we might see less
of your God of War type big yeah man
type we might see less of that it may
not be as profitable as we all think it
is especially if some of them are mad
successful you know if you if they get
like anything remotely close to a
fortnite success like remotely close to
it even if they get on there with the
Apex Legends success and they get like
one or two of those that is so massive I
find it hard to believe people that's
looking at the numbers they going to
look in them be like I wonder if we took
money out of these other games that's
not making that money and try to make
more of those games you know God of War
St
Monica can we make a a games as a
service with God of War can we can we
can we do that like like and I'm not
saying that they'll I don't think
they'll ever truly get away from making
single player over the shoulder action
adventure games I'm saying that if their
games as a service become more and more
successful they'll start to like let the
gas off the pedal a little bit Yeah
listen it's just like this man um what
Fame said they you know I the PS4
generation PlayStation had great single
player games but at the same time they
were great they were also quality
meaning they were also very expensive I
was surprised that the last of us two
only sold 10 million now 10 million is a
great number don't get me wrong but you
can tell the budget of that game was
ridiculous that that budget had to be
close to $200 million and 10 million now
don't forget Jim Ryan said this in the
interview a couple years ago their game
selling 10 to 20 million just isn't
cutting it anymore they will sell games
and nothing else no more monetization
will come from these games so them
focusing on games as a service it is
what it is but I don't know man this is
uh I just don't know man we just don't
know what's all we can do is speculate
right now and you know that that's what
we do you know I I always get annoyed
when people say you guys don't know
everything so why do you spe because i'
I've actually I've had like people in
the industry that say you know when I
listen to to to some of these podcasts
and like they have these like left to
right T
and like I know it's not that I always
laugh I'm like well that's all we
know know like we can only speculate
unless you give us more information and
I get it imagine being an executive
somewhere and and you're seeing these
off-the-wall takes these crazy takes
imagine how entertaining that would be
and being in that perspective I can
understand you're like yo is he add of
his
mind but you know that that's what we do
you know the media tries to write about
media about the games and influencers
and podcasters I consider them all
together you know I feel like we have
more of a raw uncut version of of of
that you know media generally there's
I'm sure Fame will know he runs a
website there's like five different
layers to posting an article I can get a
video out depending on how long it takes
me to record
it right yeah yeah man it's crazy bro oh
okay I don't know what to even say
anymore at this point this is uh this is
it was a this is a juggernaut um uh news
topic that came out of nowhere because
we was we was talking about something
else and lisis and the chat was hey man
Jim Ryan step down like wait a minute
stop lying to me look D I changed my
thumbnail and the title of my podcast
tonight you have to you have to I told
Al change change the title of the show
right now bro did and it works because
the thumbnail I got I got King holding
the PlayStation controller so I'm like
this is this is and you know what's
funny I told my girl when I get off this
we watching something we doing something
but now after this podcast I got to go
and be like I got to make a video real
quick like there so my videos spans at
it my video tonight is tomorrow's
video yeah man that's how you got to do
it so so you know my dark man podcast is
tomorrow and um hope I hope some more
information drop you know before the
show so that's it's going to be a lot of
fun bro let me get these super chats
real quick and I know we we don't have
Fame much longer he got a show here
really soon I do want to take on the
Fable thing real quick but let me get
these super chats real quick um $2 Super
Chat from Dan Lorenzo um Phil Spencer is
now officially the goats for $5 Super
Chat for rain uh G4 this is like when
you hear the glass breaking during the
WWE Attitude Era stone cold when Stone
Cold walks out I I I it's like it's
like that's the thing because I don't
watch a whole lot of that uh $2 super
from the Liz 22 does this open up PC day
and date
oo I think you know I think that would
benefit PlayStation tremendously they
did that but the other person that might
take over might have a Shawn Leighton
perspective and they pull back on the PC
stuff uh $2 from Hector that man uh
Macho Man dirt isn't Crazy Jim is gone
and Phil is still here $5 from boss red
77 Jim Ryan you want a place to play new
IPS and AAA games we have a place for
you it's called the PlayStation 4 snap
$5 Nintendo d theotaku IGN when uh Jim
steps down B PS boss steps down after an
amazing run IGN if Phil Spencer steps
down uh Xbox boss possibly fire as the
Xbox remains in third place yep $2 Super
Chat from ndy Jim really raised the
prices and peace
all right all right
so man I lost a little bit that I lost a
little bit with that all right so we
obviously we don't got a whole lot of
time I don't like keeping these uh long
but let let's let's talk about Fable
real quick um I'm a huge fan of what's
up with Fable I a't hear you Fable news
what you got man I heard so uh they have
a there was an article that was written
on a on a LinkedIn profile that says
that Fable is playable from beginning to
end oh oh I did read that yeah so uh
first off we don't know what that means
you know I think there was an article in
2019 saying Starfield was but Starfield
was supposed to come out in 2021 too so
you know maybe there's a difference
between
Bethesda and
um Bethesda
and you know playground games play I
don't know I actually I have a I have a
few developer friends I might reach out
to and you know get a full understanding
what playable means uh but clearly the
game is you know done to some degree
maybe it's like on the bottom level that
they have to build up to now but their
perspective of what Fable is going to be
most likely is on the screen as right
now so what do you guys think about it
like do do you think this really stands
on the fact that this game might be
coming out in like 2020 end of 2024
beginning of 2025 aable 2025 guaranteed
is it holiday or or like summer I think
it's holiday 20 well you know fall fall
2025 but then where's the outer Worlds 2
and um uh supposedly Indiana Jones is
around that
time yeah I believe Indiana Jones is
also um 2025 out of Wars yeah hey man
that's three games he said one game one
Triple A game A quarter a quarter we
might get perfect Dart it's about to get
or Gears of Wars six at that time too oh
look at that look at all the content
we're talking about brother hey Fame you
guys know know there were times we
couldn't be talking about games like
this with Xbox bro
2025 2025 we're probably going to get
whatever that Doom game was they had a
doom prequel that apparently they're
working on oh doom doom year zero yeah
Fallout 3 remake remaster like like I
don't think I said it in the video today
and I'm sure you guys can appreciate
it it's going to be really hard for
PlayStation to compete with Xbox with
this engine they got going as long as
the games generate good games and that's
obviously extremely important but it's
just like we just named like six games
and that's not to mention perfect Dart
AOW
hellblade um you know there's whatever
double finds working on like the three
unknown IPS that we saw going on at
um on Bethesda they were like project
this project that the the games is a
service you know what's crazy
PlayStation would kill to have the games
as a service that Microsoft has right
now absolutely they'll kill for a see a
thief grounded anything they'll tell
they love it bro oh man what's going on
Megatron I see you in the chat so what
do you feel Fame first off what's your
expectations on scale that you feel fa
was going to be on like is it going to
be on the top astion with like you know
um a Halo type of budget or you think
it's going to be like a a strong double
A like the original hellblade was where
do you think the scale of this game is
going to be I think because of
playground making it and I believe
playground even though we know them for
their Racers they make the greatest
racer right I think because of the
quality of Studio that we have even if
it was looked at in internally of
Microsoft as a big AA I think because of
the quality of the studio we're going to
get that big triaa experience um I I do
feel there the big focus of this game is
going to be giving us that that classic
Fable feel because talk about ruining
the name if you don't give people that
that classic uh you know humor and
things like that they have to be able to
do that right I do think that the the
importance of this game being good is
very important to Microsoft and and to
playgrounds because it's it it moves
them from just being the for of
developers even though we we know it's a
separate team it goes them from just
being the for developers to actually
getting more respect from people from
being that big Triple H Studio that can
make a story that can that that can
build character and stuff like that I
think the skel game is going to be big
uh I don't expect any disappointment
because I I think we know what we're
getting from playground which is biology
the purose until we see otherwise
quality look look 100 prove otherwise
it's quality look at my uh my brother's
girlfriend's dog this thing always
shakes it doesn't matter what time it is
like it shakes
247 like like look at him he's cute
though besides it's like it's a girl
she's cute though besides like her big
eyes like you hey I appreciate the
invite to get ready for 2 XP oh yeah for
sure man you got a big show coming up oh
yeah I'm I'm I'm sending I'm sending
them all over to you man I'm sending
them all big show coming up man hey I
appreciate y y'all take it easy all
right man see you all right bro man huh
I want this crazy adct it's crazy man
it's and I think this shows it's I think
the reason that if he did get pushed out
did you hear me I'm I'm on the podcast I
think the reason that if he did get
pushed out it wasn't necessarily him not
making the money it was he let so so
much stuff happened under his watch with
competition yeah cuz if you think about
it when he took over up until now Xbox
is a completely different company mhm
and you know I don't know if they're
looking at that as like an l and it's
like you know we we expected you to
maintain these relationships better or
maybe maybe it was maybe you know he
made promises that he could stop that
Activision too it is kind of ironic that
he retires right before the Activision
was even approved you know maybe he did
say you know what I got some people some
friends at the CMA I got some friends
maybe that's the reason the CMA was
extra extra about it because let's be
honest I I don't know you know I'm not
conspiracy theory yeah but let's be
honest though maybe he he guaranteed
something know I got some friends at the
CMA they're gonna block the deal and
they
did for a whole two
weeks but he didn't have friends at the
EU and everywhere else and they didn't
they made sure to did so uh this is this
is uh this is crazy man you know I was
just thinking to myself earlier today
where I was like man why I'm G talk
about a dark man tomorrow
H don't worry about that
anymore yeah so let let's let's try to
get the rest of these topics
TGs
aftermath I want to talk about the Sha
Lon thing again
man yeah it's no uh the Jim Ryan thing
oh okay we're bro8 minutes
in an hour eight minutes
in all right so TGs
aftermath did you watch it and if you
didn't watch it did you know what got
announced yeah yeah I watched it I
thought it was okay I thought last it
was a decent show I actually thought the
state of play that PlayStation just did
I thought that uh that TGs was better H
I didn't really like cuz if you really
take away like the Spider-Man they
already shown and and you know Final
Fantasy for me what did that state of
play really show yeah nothing much um
listen I liked it man when you see the
uh you know when you just continue to
see the relationship between Sega and
Xbox man and like all of those games
like some of these games are not my cup
of te but someone like you who's who's
an American or Xbox fan do you love
jrpgs the announcements had some of the
Yakuza announcements like some of those
other games some of them going to Game
Pass I think that was I thought it was a
pretty decent show like I I remember
last year being a little bit better in
my opinion but still man for Xbox to
have a show at the Tokyo game show
announced some titles coming to the
platform and you know there were times
you know like we mentioned this before
add there were times last well I was say
earlier this generation or last
generation I said Xbox just a get out of
Japan they don't rock out with you Xbox
just for get it and Phil Spencer no no
he's like no we are going to continue to
try our best in Japan and that's what
they're doing bro so and respect to them
because it's like a lot of people cuz
you know it wasn't just you there was so
many Xbox people cuz I have so many jrpg
they need to do better in the in this my
channel you can mistake my channel for a
Japanese role playing Channel like if
you didn't know better uh and in a way
that's kind of true you know I I I am
very Advocate on Xbox doing better and I
think the reason people would think that
is because I make so much content
because I because I do believe as a real
big fan of the old final fantasies of
Japanese role playing games like Persona
and stuff in general that those games
are essential to make sure that you can
compete in
today's modern uh Society like it's hard
to compete with these companies like
PlayStation if you don't have those with
you to help you fight those
battles agreed agreed so you know like
there was times last generation where
people were saying Phi Spencer going to
Japan for nothing the Japanese markets
don't care about Xbox or Field Spencer
and you know what they're still not not
killing it in Japan but you have to try
and they're continuing to try and
they're bringing jrpgs and Japanese
games from Japanese developers to the
Xbox brand and like I said earlier some
of them are in Game Pass day one and I
think that's huge bro because you got to
cater to everybody man you just can't be
a shooter box you just can't be a single
player behind the shoulder story driven
game box you got to cater to as many
people as you can because everybody
obviously don't like the same
thing yeah I feel you and it's just like
it's all about being diverse and giving
your audience multiple things to play I
think that's the most important thing
out of everything uh let me get these
super chats real quick uh we're going to
be in the show here in about 10 minutes
uh Mr Man and and and
them uh let me make sure I because you
guys have just been so generous this
thing it's it's hard for me to keep up
with all
these
okay IG when IGN steps
down oh yeah okay
so$ from Nintendo daku first off I want
to thank you for giving me that uh that
link he DM me that link uh the crazy
part is Jim doesn't have a single game
under his name every game that has
dropped so far was from leighton's era
he only uh he has only closed Studios
he's got kind of a point there I even
think about that he's right yeah $5 from
from uh the angry therapist MD Phil
about to tell the world we welcome
Playstation
Xbox $2 sh from Mr mans andm uh Phil
saved Xbox and
Playstation $2 Super Chat from the angry
therapist Jim got let go because of the
remix
showcase oh you guys are just super chat
like crazy man U $5 super from bone
slave um only a man who knows his job in
uh is in Jeopardy Will Travel Country to
Country to block a dill they gave him
ultimatum I don't know but $2 Super Chat
from Spartan 661 Jim got to see the
world on Sony's dollar before he left he
kind of did I mean he let's be real that
man seen the world before that day uh $5
$5 super shot from Jack 82 in all
seriousness I don't cheer for people
losing their jobs Jim probably left
because of f being away from family or
something personal I agree uh you know
it's just curious on if he left
willingly or like he was coming close to
where he could just retire and he's like
I'm out that's my only real question $2
from Dwayne uh Koto Dwayne Koto I don't
know Kito Kito I like
that long live the king of gameplay Phil
Spencer so let me before we go out here
I'm going to go to the live chat we're
going to do a poll real
quick poll time
did Jim Ryan leave
willingly on his
own that's a good question yes or no bam
that's a good question all right so guys
I answer that it's in the chat right now
I'm kind of curious The Vibes of the
community the uh you know exactly what
you guys think
it's a good question
man did Jim so we already have 54 uh
votes uh 89% said no 11% said yes what
show uh I will send you to the show King
King will be on talking about this don't
worry about that even if um DK gotta go
I will still stay until they go live um
100 said no 17 16 yeah they they being
mad crazy with this
man uh 83% said no 17% said yes we got
126 votes already yeah it's Level One
gaming I think here here's the thing
it's like I said it regardless what El
it's in relevant he's leaving I'm
curious who they replace him with and
I'm curious CU we got the same thing to
worry about if Phil Spencer left what is
that next to going to do yeah you know
and we got to be real here Phil
Spencer's been doing just this role for
like 10 years now yeah like he's
probably on the on the outs of retiring
too I was actually told that he was
going to
retire before the Bethesda de B was yeah
and um you know part of the agreement to
buying Bethesda was he would stay on for
the transition you get what I'm saying
cuz he's dude look at Phil when he took
over now this job is stressful
yeah it's definitely stressful uh people
have a good uh who takes over if Phil
leaves that's a good
question a lot of people Matt booty I
don't I don't think it's going to be
Sarah bond for some reason I feel like
Sarah Bon's going to
Activision I don't know why was that
something beat on your end yeah oh okay
I thought it was something my my I
thought my
probably they how about Mike
Yara oh Paris lock car said just heard
Phil's name but
false I don't know if he's talking about
if Sarah Bond or you know what I was
told talking about like retiring or
something uh Paris lockart works for XO
uh Microsoft so I and that's what I was
just told man retiring oh okay look man
Phil getting up there in age man we we
we got to start discussing if he does
retire who's going to take him I I
assume Paris he don't want to do this
for the rest of his life yeah of course
not yeah it's it's mad stressful it's
stressful me covering it I can't imagine
how stressful it is for someone on the
head of one of the things that we're
covering it's not that he's old it's
just like look like a lot of people
don't retire to a certain age because
they're still you know building up their
retirement fun or they like Phil
probably got the bread to leave right
now if you wanted to yeah of course uh
once you get to the certain things and
you're making a certain amount of money
it's a different level when you retire
you don't just retire when you hit 65
anymore right of
course you make sure you ready to
retire yeah um especially you make their
kind of money Phil will be in Ai and run
Xbox
forever oh man I think when it comes
down to it man you know people retire
when they need to at the end of the day
yeah I mean I think that's all you can
say I do think sarahan is going to
Activision I know that's probably wrong
but I think sarahan going to Activision
just makes sense you know I think she
would she would like gravitate over
there really easily maybe because it
does look like they've been really you
know grooming her to take over Phil
Spencer's spot it really does but but I
think if if she does go to Activision
because that was the initial
plan but who's going to take over Bobby
and I don't think I don't think they're
just going to give that to anyone it's
gonna have to be someone to make sense
because of things that's going on over
there when they bought Bethesda they
didn't have you know the stuff that was
going on at Bethesda like they have at
Activision uh says no we need Sarah bond
to bring home Xbox for
first I mean to bring
Sega oh Sega well you know cuz at first
you know um Phil is taking over Bobby
spot but like you said Phil ain't gonna
be there forever Phil is 55 years old so
he's getting up there in age um so he's
been spotted on yachs outside
Miami I'm sure I'm sure these executives
are always on yachs to some degree oh
heck yeah man yeah they get invited
there for like some meeting or they're
just on vacation
I'm sure some of these Executives own a
yacht uh you know these people aren't
they got some money in the bank account
man that's why I said don't don't sit
there and say cuz Phil ain't 75 he can't
retire Phil can I mean sh Jim Ryan is
announcing retirement and he's younger
than Phil yeah shoot man Phil Phil is
I'm I'm sure Phil like you think Phil
get paid six um seven or eight fig I
think seven figures probably but he's
he's fine he's probably high six figures
it'd be crazy if he high high six
figures got his position seven figures I
don't know I've never really into
people's money like that but to think
you make a million plus dollars that'd
be crazy yeah I mean High position I
mean he does to my knowledge he would
get paid like a lot of uh bonuses and
stuff so he's on the board I don't know
see I don't know how stuff like that
works I don't know how much those kind
of people make
um maybe I don't
know let's see if Google knows how much
Phil spiter makes I think it's seven
figures bro he how much money does Phil
Spencer make at
Xbox oh they have a whole page dedicated
this this stuff man Dam all Phil
Spencer's Network Phil SP is an American
business executive who has a net worth
of $25
million so so that that's how much he he
he got in assets and stuff right now 25
million Phil makes 8 million a year I
don't know the math the math doesn't add
up the math doesn't it's not mathing
right okay like he's a big time is if if
if if he is worth 25 million you mean to
tell me that no you guys are pocket
watching no I brought it up I brought it
up I brought it up so that mean he
that's a lot of money he be making like
crazy every year uh yeah you're right he
he probably pays a lot a lot in taxes oh
that's kind of interesting I've never
known how like Executives and stuff
Twitter says he's worth 25 million like
as of right now like as of right now so
you meaned to tell me what eight he said
$8 million is that what they said that
they think he makes a
year
y so he's made
uh yeah that might be right though yeah
I'm might be right I don't know maybe $2
million a year see I think 8 million is
a little too I don't know man may maybe
these Executives be making it out like
that I I
would I don't know I don't know I don't
know how much these people make 10
million after tax is like eight uh $68
million but you got to consider he's
been there for a while so he's been
making that kind of money for a minute
and he's worth 25 million and Phil
Spencer don't like look like the type of
person have like lamori outside house he
like a regular guy just a lot of asset a
lot of now don't get wrong he probably
has some very luxurous premium
stuff but I just don't see him driving
like a Bugatti down the road no he's not
that tight he's not that type so it's
just like he kind of seems like the
person that's like you know when it
matters he going to spend that extra
extra money a Suburban
Outback a Suburban
Outback you can spend up to 125 million
at Microsoft without a boore
approval you're live with this Jim F
around and find out let me get these
super chats and send you guys on your
way
man okay uh $2 Super Chat from God
Emperor sofa king king said they packed
him
up uh five up super TR for the angry
therapist MD all these third party deals
he made to keep games off Xbox backfired
on JY look at how many of these deals
failed look at look at
Square yeah I fil him on that I don't
know I don't know how much of that stuff
goes uh we don't really know too much
when it comes to that who me the deal
ended uh 301 votes and 78% of you said
no
seriously Jim leaving like Gone Gone yes
Jessie B he is gone gone with a capital
G he he gone
man G gone hash Sony mismanagement I
wonder how Phil feels about this I'm
sure Phil will twe uh will tweet
something soon like you know have you
know like like congratulations all your
re something like that here's the
question it what
kind what kind of thought proc processes
at Microsoft like is it like worry a
little bit because at least Phil was the
at least Jim Ryan was the person they
knew or is it a little worried on who's
they replacing him with no I think Xbox
is so confident and and everything they
have right now I don't think it matters
to them you what can Sony do
to to counter
ABK by take two they can't afford that
you know what I'm saying
all right let's go ahead and pull out of
this podcast uh we 25 minutes in doing
our outros so
DT where are you going to be at what's
going on tell the chat where you at uh
today's been a Monumental episode it's
not very often that stuff happens live
on my show uh you know it's not very
often stuff stuff happens on IL either
because it's on Sunday most news unless
Jason Sher does something most news
don't come out
hey yo I'm putting my channel in the
chat check it out I will have a oneman
podcast tomorrow discussing this and
trust me um I'm going to have fun I'm
going to talk some trash I'm not going
to lie to you I'mma tell you guys up I'm
going to talk a lot of trash but at the
end of the day you know the guy is
retiring for whatever reason but we're
going to discuss all of that we we're
going to have some fun tomorrow at 6:00
pm Eastern Standard Time I'm putting my
channel in the chat so guys tune in stop
by Pro Xbox Channel we talk a lot of
trash we have a lot of fun make sure you
put your Twitter in there too yeah I
always forget to do my Twitter yeah
because that I would actually argue it
makes more sense to put your Twitter in
there than your YouTube channel because
at least you have the engagement from
your Twitter and then they go to your
Twitter and follow to YouTube Because if
you think about it when you find a new
content creator or something you usually
go to their Twitter from like a Social
Media stuff and find the rest of their
stuff yep you're right let me put it let
me put my Twitter in here hey yo is B
you ask me if I having crap on listen I
thought about it man but a lot of the
homies including the people in the chat
was like uh well no I tell that back the
people in the chat said yes but some of
my homies like man if you had crap on I
might have come in that day so I don't
know man I might have them on eventually
so we'll see yeah I'm putting my Twitter
in right here my ex that's just so weird
X um so my podcast tomorrow my Onan
podcast tomorrow we going to have some
fun man I'm making a thumbnail right
after the show so I'm so I can just be
prepared yeah it's gonna be fun man so
Kofi uh from uh press star uh I don't
know why I keep saying press star he
don't do that no more he said people
celebrating Jim Ryan uh retirement have
you ever considered the next person
appointed can be
worse yeah that's a good point that's
why I'm always nervous about like Phil
Spencer leaving CU it's like I don't
know what the next two going to say you
know he he might not really care about
the Xbox brand like that we might get a
chip
right someone that like doesn't gain
because that's my biggest thing that I
think really Vibes with us when it comes
to you
know what's going on right now I think
that's what vies with me is the fact
that we know Phil games we know he's
playing these games with us how many
times I get on Xbox and I see him
playing a game like bro all the time hey
may you when when the leak happened Feld
was playing Starfield when the leak
happened because somebody posted it last
week he just like I guess I can't stop
at at this point right but you know I
appreciate every for coming through man
it's been a a fantastic
show let me get this Super Chat oh you
get that I he's talking about let me see
he's talking to you a come on let me see
who this is where is it uh Raiden
blade I don't see it yet oh Rick oh come
on man R Blade with the five pounds hi
dark dark Wonderman Jim lost all ABK
field offer him ABK and Jim got Cod Jim
got US Congress and jftc looking like T
Jim t t Jim hey man don't call me Doc
one how dare you question
whoa I just it's like a like a light
bulb what what happens if he's getting
pushed
out because he didn't take the initial
deal what happens if he pushed at them
and was like look I know that that
Microsoft offering us this 10-year deal
and we can get all of Activision games
but I'm telling you I can block it I'm
telling you right now don't sign this
let me block it and they and they and
they and they went with him and he
didn't get a
blocked you think
so it would it would be interesting it
would be very interesting I guess we
could stop with the conspiracy theories
yeah all right so I'm going send you
guys over here to fame guys um first off
I want to thank everyone coming through
you guys were so generous today you guys
don't know how much that means uh you
know not even the fact that super chats
the likes are up the views are up we had
almost 800 people in here it was a great
podcast man uh you know I love when big
news gets announced either I love when
it gets announced on the day or the day
before not not not not
daring actually I probably would have
preferred this to get announced like 10
minutes before the show so I could have
prepared to share daring it but it was
nice man it was nice it was nice yeah
it's cool man it's all good you know we
had a great show bro all right so let me
send you guys over here to fame uh King
will be on the show by the way he'll be
on here probably in the next 5 to 10
minutes I think you guys are
uh that show's going to be crazy man
it's going to be crazy but we're going
to get you on over there uh you know $2
for from Raiden blade adct On My Level
appreciate it man so go over there to to
to that podcast sit in the chat wait for
uh they got the countdown going on right
now they probably getting King it's
probably they're going to probably be a
little late going on because it takes
for a minute to get King uh on the show
so I'm sure I'm sure he gonna be over
there but I will send you guys over
there and I hope you guys have a good
day peace out y'all and I I'm watching
myself because we're GNA see King go
crazy you don't need a link it's going
to be in it's going to show up in the
chat when I end it cuz I'm raiding them
but I appreciate for coming through and
then until next time you guys have a
good day peace crazy